we're gonna look at some of your film
and we're gonna see what it's said about
them and then you try and guess which
one it is as cash grabs go this one is
delightfully unconcerned with coolers
and I have to pick what movie though
yeah
was that why him
Oh power they're always right how about
this one
this movie is stupid and I like stupid
fun there's a compliment that was the
best review for this movie that was for
Jumanji was it for Jumanji
does it go too far at times absolutely
but it is a damn funny movie for shizzle
my nizzle how did I do that but shizzle
my nizzle I doubt this soul plane was
good enough to get a ripe tomato so
playing okay alright I didn't know that
we made a proper sized blockbuster where
the humans are wholly incidental is it
an animated feature No you want me to
answer the question for you no what do
you tell this is in jeopardy
Godzilla did you see that yeah they just
forgot that he did got it and let me
launch into this one no matter how sick
you are of him okay let me read that
again no matter how sick you are of him
Kevin Hart is always bound to make you
laugh
no matter how sick what movie do I think
I made people sick in let's see yeah we
have time yeah let me go down the list
that was for what now for what now yeah
you attacked my comedy specials because
best a firecracker up the backside of
the bloated modern action G Oh was that
drive yeah that's a dominant Corey
flicks that coat down my neck
I got your name
[Music]
[Music]